the governor of Missouri is rejecting
allegations of blackmail this morning
after admitting he cheated on his wife
Republican Eric Greitens says the affair
happened before his election the woman's
ex-husband tells our st. Louis affiliate
that's KMOV the governor threatened to
reveal her identity
Brighton's lawyer says well that claim
is just false Jericka Duncan is here
with what the station's investigation
has found out Jericho good morning good
morning and they spent a year
investigating this our affiliate KMOV
says the unnamed woman involved in the
affair was the governor's hairdresser
and that her now ex-husband was the one
who exposed the sexual encounter and
alleged blackmail which included nude
photographs Eric Greitens hours after
his State of the State address Wednesday
night Missouri first term Republican
governor and former Navy SEAL Eric
Greitens admitted he was unfaithful to
his wife recordings obtained by our st.
Louis affiliate KMOV which CBS News has
not independently verified appear to
show the unnamed woman detailing her
consensual sexual encounter with the
governor to her then-husband only days
after it happened
[Music]
you some sort of date I don't know what
it was and tapes my hands to be I am a
very proud husband and father
the governor's affair was exposed by the
now ex-husband of the woman involved
KMOV chose to protect his identity I
think it's as bad as it gets when
somebody takes advantage of somebody our
first lady and my wife Sheena great uns
shortly after the report aired governor
Greitens and his wife Sheena released a
joint statement saying before Eric was
elected governor there was a time when
he was unfaithful in our marriage Eric
took responsibility but despite the
governor's admission his attorney says
the blackmail accusation is a lie saying
the outrageous claims of improper
conduct regarding these almost three
year ago events are false
governor Greitens says his wife has
forgiven him and they've emerged
stronger meanwhile at least one member
of the Missouri State Senate is already
calling for his resignation Norah odd
story yeah yeah there's tape and
handcuffs or taping and pull ups and the
hairdresser well his hair did look good
up so I'm hoping he's doing something
differently now very sad story all the
way around
tareka thank you thank you Jericho